[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les fluides supercritiques la
matière peut exister sous différents
états dans notre quotidien à la surface
de la terre
ces états sont au nombre de trois
solides liquides et gaz chacune de ces
trois formes correspond à une certaine
configuration microscopiques dans un
solide les molécules sont fixés les unes
par rapport aux autres
elle respecte une structure régulière
car elles sont fortement liés dans un
liquide
les molécules sont liées plus faiblement
et elles sont ainsi libre de se déplacer
mais tout en gardant une certaine
cohésion un liquide peut donc se
déformer de façon fluide mais il
conserve un certain volume
contrairement au gaz dans lesquelles les
molécules sont libres de leurs
mouvements et qui épouse alors le volume
tout entier dans lequel ils sont
contenus en fonction de la température
et de la pression du milieu qui
l'entourent accor va se manifester
naturellement sous l'un de ces états par
exemple sous la pression atmosphérique
et pour une température entre 0 et 100
degrés celsius
l'eau se trouve naturellement à l'état
liquide ce sont les conditions que réuni
notre atmosphère et c'est pour cette
raison qu'on peut trouver de l'eau
liquide sur la planète
mais pour cette même pression si la
température de l'eau et de 200 degrés
celsius alors celle-ci sera
naturellement à l'état de gaz de la
vapeur d'eau dans l'optique de
schématiser les conditions nécessaires à
la présence de chacun des trois états on
peut réaliser ce qu'on appelle un
diagramme de phase
intel diagramme représente la phase de
l'eau c'est à dire tout simplement
l'état dans lequel elle se trouve
naturellement pour différentes valeurs
de pression et de température on
commence par se munir d'un récipient
bien hermétique dans lequel on va placer
de l'eau la température dans notre
récipient peut être réglé en le
chauffant ou en le refroidissant et la
pression peut être modifier à l'aide
d'un piston qui va appuyer ou tirer sur
la paroi pour remplir le diagramme on va
se munir de trois couleurs par exemple
on peut choisir du gris pour l'état de
gaz du bleu ciel pour l'état liquide et
du bleu foncé pour l'état solide
en chaque point du diagramme on associe
une certaine température et une certaine
pression qu'on va venir régler
directement sur le récipient
une fois le réglage fait on observe la
phase dans laquelle se trouve le haut à
l'intérieur du récipient et on peut
alors placé un petit carré sur le
diagramme dont la couleur représente cet
état en répétant ce procédé pour de
multiples valeurs on obtient finalement
une sorte de carte sur laquelle
apparaissent trois zones pour comprendre
si la pression et la température sont
telles qu'on se trouve dans l'une de ces
zones par exemple la zone bleue foncée
cela signifie que dans de telles
conditions de pression et de température
l'eau se trouve naturellement sous sa
forme solide une des première chose qui
saute aux yeux est le fait que les trois
zones sont délimitées entre elles par
des courbes bien spécifiques
lorsqu'on se trouve à la jonction entre
deux zones
alors les phases qui sont de part et
d'autre de cette ligne peuvent coexister
toutes les deux ensemble de façon stable
par exemple lorsqu'on va chauffer un
glaçon sous la pression atmosphérique
on va progressivement se déplacer vers
la droite du diagramme car sa
température augmente
au moment où on atteint la limite de la
zone solide pour une température de 0
degrés celsius les toutes premières
gouttes d'eau apparaissent sous forme
liquide
progressivement le glaçon va fondre tout
en restant à la même température
l'énergie qu'on lui fournit en chauffant
n'est plus utilisée pour augmenter sa
température
mais pour le faire fondre c'est à dire
pour réarranger est séparé ces molécules
à l'échelle microscopique
une fois la transition terminée lorsque
le glaçon a entièrement fondu sa
température va pouvoir augmenter de
nouveau et on passe alors dans la zone
du diagramme qui correspond à l'état
liquide
on a effectué ce qu'on appelle une
transition de phase on est passé d'un
état de la matière à un autre en
traversant l'une de ses courbes
séparatrice une autre remarque
intéressante consiste à observer qu'il
existe un point sur lequel se touchent
les trois zones
ce point sur le diagramme est
directement en contact avec chacun des
états de la matière solide liquide et
gaz si on se place dans de telles
conditions de température et de pression
il est ainsi possible de faire coexister
à la fois de l'eau sous forme solide
liquide et gazeuse
on appelle ce point bien particulier le
point triple dans le cas de l'eau ce
point triple correspond à une pression
de 0,6 pour cent d'atmosphère et à une
température de 1 centième de degré
celsius ce sont des conditions qui ne
sont pas naturellement réunis sur terre
mais si on les applique en laboratoire
ce phénomène est bel et bien possible et
on peut étonnamment faire bouillir de
l'eau tout en la faisant simultanément
gelé
enfin la remarque qui va le plus nous
intéressait sur ce diagramme et le fait
que la courbe qui sépare l'état liquide
de l'état gaz semble brusquement
s'arrêter ce point bien particulier où
la courbe s'arrête et appelé le point
critique
il correspond à une température et à une
pression très élevé des conditions qui
ne sont pas naturellement réunis sur
terre mais qu'on peut infliger à une
substance en laboratoire reprenons notre
récipient qui contient de l'eau et
ajustant sa pression et sa température
de sorte à se placer sur cette ligne
comme on l'a vu sur la courbe qui sépare
les deux zones
l'eau se manifestent simultanément dans
deux états différents
en l'occurrence sous une phase liquide
et une phase gazeuse
quand on observe le récipient on voit
alors une séparation entre le liquide et
le gaz on va maintenant chauffer et
progressivement compresser le récipient
de sorte à se rapprocher petit à petit
du point critique mais tout en restant
sur la courbe pas à pas la pression dans
le récipient augmente les molécules
d'eau dans le gaz sont ainsi fortement
comprimé elle se rapproche les unes des
autres et occupe donc moins de place la
vapeur d'eau devient de plus en plus
dense
d'autre part la température en
augmentant va forcer les molécules dans
le liquide à s'agiter de plus en plus
fort de cette façon les molécules du
liquide sont de moins en moins liées
entre elles et leur agitation toujours
plus forte des oblige à occuper
davantage d' espace l'eau liquide
devient donc de moins en moins denses la
surface qui sépare le liquide de la
vapeur est alors de moins en moins
visibles elle apparaît de plus en plus
floue quand soudain la densité du
liquide qui diminue et celle du gaz qui
augmente atteignent la même valeur à
partir de ce moment les deux phases ne
sont plus distinctes le liquide et le
gaz dans le récipient ont désormais
exactement la même densité on obtient
une sorte de mélange homogène du liquide
et du gaz c'est ce point sur le
diagramme qu'on appelle le point
critique au delà de ce point il est
impossible de distinguer le gaz du
liquide
les deux phases sont confondus elles ont
en quelque sorte fusionner pour n'en
former plus qu'une seule l'état de l'eau
dans le récipient n'est ni gaz ni
liquide elle se comporte de façon très
similaire à un gaz mais elle présente
aussi certaines propriétés troublante
qui la rapproche d'un liquide
on dit que l'eau sous cet état est un
fluide supercritique
premièrement il est intéressant de noter
que contrairement à l'état solide l'état
liquide et gaz ne sont pas indépendants
bien qu'on puisse passer du liquide au
gaz par une transition de phase par
exemple en faisant bouillir de l'eau
il est également possible de passer d'un
liquide à un gaz sans jamais effectué de
transition pour ce faire il suffit tout
simplement d'ajuster progressivement la
température et la pression dans notre
récipients de sorte à contourner la
courbe qui sépare les deux états sur le
diagramme en suivant ce procédé on part
d'un liquide et en passant par un fluide
supercritique
on arrive à un gaz on appelle ce genre
de procédés un contournement du point
critique
cette expérience est impressionnante à
observer car il est très inhabituel de
voir un liquide devenir vapeur sans
qu'aucune transition ne soit visible
quand on s'approche progressivement du
point critique avec un fluide
supercritique
on peut observer un phénomène très
étonnant au moment d'atteindre son point
critique
le fluide se met naturellement à
diffuser la lumière
on appelle ce phénomène l'opa les sens
critique
ceci est dû à la réfraction de la
lumière à l'intérieur du fluide c'est à
dire au ralentissement des ondes
lumineuses en fonction de sa densité en
se rapprochant du point critique
le fluide va devoir se séparer en deux
une phase liquide et une phase gazeuse
mais juste avant tout se passe comme si
les molécules hésité entre une phase et
l'autre ces sortes d'hésitation au sein
du fluide entraînent de très fortes
fluctuations de densité qui vont
diffuser la lumière de la même façon que
notre atmosphère diffuse la lumière du
soleil pour donner sa couleur au ciel
dans notre quotidien les fluides
supercritiques sont utilisées pour de
nombreuses applications leurs propriétés
sont très intéressantes notamment bien
qu'intel fluide se comporte
principalement comme un gaz il peut être
utilisé comme solvant
c'est à dire qu'il permet d'extraire
certaines substances on utilise
notamment beaucoup le dioxyde de carbone
supercritique pour extraire des arômes
de plantes la nicotine du tabac ou même
retiré la caféine du café un gros
avantage du co2 supercritique et que
contrairement aux autres solvants et
liquides
il n'est pas toxique et est relativement
simple et rapide à utiliser pour une
puissance d'extraction très efficace
sous sa forme supercritique l'eau est
également un très bon solvants elle est
très utile pour détruire des déchets
organiques sans pour autant dégagé de
gaz nocifs
contrairement au cas où les brûlerait
les fluides supercritiques sont utiles
pour une multitude d'applications
diverses et variées comme la production
de carburant pour des systèmes de
réfrigération ou même pour leurs
propriétés antimicrobiennes pour
conclure le fluide supercritique
consiste à lui seul un état à part
entière de la matière au delà d'une
certaine pression et d'une certaine
température les phase liquide et gazeuse
semble fusionner ne forment plus qu'un
seul état homogène qui possède à la fois
des propriétés de gaz et des propriétés
de liquide
sur terre les conditions de température
et de pression sont trop faibles pour
permettre l'existence de telles fluide à
l'état naturel
il est tout de même possible d'en
trouver de petites quantités mais
seulement au fond des océans au sein de
cheminées hydrothermales là où la
température et la pression deviennent
suffisamment extrême mais s'il est rare
sur terre
l'état de fluides supercritiques est
cependant relativement commun dans
l'univers et en particulier à
l'intérieur des planètes gazeuses dans
leur atmosphère les conditions de
pression et de température sont si
extrêmes que certaines couches de gaz
sont en fait supercritique de même
l'atmosphère très chaude et très épaisse
de vénus peut atteindre 500 degrés
celsius pour une pression presque 100
fois plus élevée que sur terre sous de
telles conditions
l'atmosphère presque entièrement composé
de dioxyde de carbone se manifeste comme
un fluide supercritique
[Musique]